this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [ __ ] it's
monday the 23rd of may listen the joint
is brought to you by manscape are you
ready to go ultra smooth our friends of
manscape are here to help
grab your handy lawnmower 4.0 for a nice
trim
then you pull out the crop exfoliator
and you explode exfoliate around the
[ __ ] pogo stick then you lather up
and you see you're shaving with the
clear crop gel shaving gel
just for the [ __ ] groin area and then
it's time to shave you use the crop
shaver it's designed for shaving around
the [ __ ] helmet of the [ __ ] and all
the products in the ultra smooth package
of vegan cruelty free and sulfate full
sulfate free no animals got kicked in
the head with this experiment
get 20 percent off plus free shipping at
manscape.com with code joey j-o-e-y it's
summer time you want to keep that
[ __ ] area spotless if it's looking
like the wolf man you're going to jerk
off to your [ __ ] 90 nothing's going
to happen for you i'm going to give you
20 off on a monday plus free shipping
with code joey at manscape.com
smooth out the [ __ ] dick area and
relaunch the ultra smooth package from
the fellas at
manscape.com listen i'm gonna thank you
manscape is gonna thank you but most
importantly
your [ __ ] balls are gonna thank you
when was the last time they said thank
you about anything the joint is also
brought to you by the bong of the year
freeze pipe no matter if it's 100
degrees like it is today you keep your
bong ice [ __ ] cold here's how it
works
you freeze a portion of the bong
then when you're ready to [ __ ] smoke
it you pack it with the [ __ ] wreath
for a deck the laughing gas and then you
take that top piece out of the freezer
you pip it into your [ __ ]
bubbler or bong whatever and when you
rip the hot smoke passage through the
frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale
like a bad [ __ ] your smoke will
be so cold
you think you're blowing ice cubes up
people's [ __ ] listen i love freeze
pipe it takes me back to 83 snowmass
just getting a scoop of snow and putting
in a bung it's non-toxic it freezes
faster than water and guess what it
stays frozen longer it must be on blue
chew freeze pipe cools down
the smoke by hundreds of degrees
what happens is your [ __ ] throat
doesn't burn and you're living like a
doctor you can sing operating [ __ ] and
your uncle joey's taking care of you on
a monday morning go to freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
off your first order listen i'd start
off with the [ __ ] bubbler and work
yourself up to the bung the pipe the
whole [ __ ] thing that's the
freezepipe.com
pressing code joey j-o-e-y
to save 10
if you could smoke from it
freeze pipe makes it [ __ ] i love
you let's get this party started on a
monday morning
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah bruce lee was the real it was the
real deal no he could fight
fight
that [ __ ] turned the nation
around i mean i i grew up in the in the
you know a lot of people though well
some people know but i grew up in the
fight game because my dad was a bus
driver obviously obviously from bronx
dale but he also was a uh a professional
fight trainer
and so i grew up uh boxing not never
professionally never i just trained and
you know when i grew up and i i didn't
want to be a fighter i wanted to be
you know i wanted to be an actor
but my dad
always said
that you know you could you know you
could be good with your hands but if you
fight a guy who's good was arrested like
a wrestler a wrestler was it was the
toughest kind of fight in the street in
the street in the street arrested i
bounced joey and my son said you got to
tell joey that story because he's into
martial arts i said all right i'll tell
them i was when i was a ballast in 1981
i was a bouncer in uh the limelight in
manhattan it was like the hottest club
in the neighborhood i must have walked
past you three you mustered you had to
because i used to work the door and the
only guy
you know i got it to somebody i was
always they call me the perry como
because i was always like cool like i
wouldn't like i said come on relax you
don't want to fight i was a good talker
right but this one [ __ ] guy got into
and i was about i squared him up they
hit him and he went down on me and he
you know he gave me a double double leg
yeah double leg i'll never forget i told
him the story and he got he i found out
later he was he was an all-american
college wrestler he got me down on the
floor and then i remember i'll never
forget it joey i grabbed his shoulders
to roll him
it was like i was picking up a building
joey i couldn't move no
like he just knew how to brace me
joey i was like
i felt like a child i felt like a baby
and thank god the cavalry came my other
bounces and they got him but if they
didn't come forget it i was getting my
ass kicked man it's crazy the power that
a wrestler has they have a lot of
strength because they they train in
endurance based right and the more the
years that you keep wrestling you just
get this brute strength that you can't
get from weights
weights can't give you that type of
strength right you learn to be heavy
you know they learn how to be heavy yes
it's a tough thing i didn't like
wrestling at that age at 15 i didn't
want to hug no guys
you know what i'm saying i wanted to
play basketball right but you did you
did jiu jitsu i did jiu jitsu i joined
when i was 50.
50. yeah wow and i go today
you still go yeah
uh gracie and old bridge they have an
old guy class wow every day from 12. an
old guy class there's a guy in there
charlie he's a gangster from staten
island he's really he's [ __ ] 60.
i asked him charlie what do you do
because i sell businesses i buy and sell
business i'm 60 years old i bet you you
better not [ __ ] with this guy this guy
is a black belt in karate all his life
uh and then he started one again when he
was 55
and the other day me and him were
[ __ ] around having a great time with
both old-timers i really went to
scissors sweeping so i pulled them into
my guard and i put my leg in between
them and i just i was ready to scissor
sweep him he didn't budge
he didn't [ __ ] budge guys right all
the technique in the world because you
got to put that weight on top of yours
he's a big italian dude and i went to
sweep him nothing it was like pushing
against the wall and the lady told me he
was a wrestler yeah because i wrestled
in college because i dropped it you know
after college yeah but i picked it up
again with jiu jitsu but what you said
is an interesting thing that even way
it's like they get that
they get that
it's a different grip strength you know
it's a different strength it's funny
because i joined jiu jitsu because i was
sick and tired of watching people
watch stuff and
like put down jiu jitsu i wanted to make
sure i knew what i was talking about
right you know i wanted to make sure i
understood it and i went to vegas with
rogan one time and that was when
mcgregor was going to fight diaz the
first time right and i'll never forget
that diaz he's diaz went like this and
mcgregor squinted
and i went and i thought about it all
night like after the after the weigh-in
i bet like maybe 20 bucks yeah just to
watch the fight and then i went to my
room and i started thinking about i'm
like
diaz is a jiu jitsu guy right
all his life from the beginning that's a
different strength
that's a different strength right that's
a different endurance level
i go you know what i'm going to bet d i
never forget calling my wife and go and
put money in the atm account and she's
like for what what what are you i go
just i'll show you i bought like a
thousand on diaz i couldn't believe you
probably got good odds yeah i know he
beat
yeah that was the only reason i bet him
i could tell you all that's the only
reason because
that discipline
you can't it's you can't take that
[Music]
my old uh jiu-jitsu trainer was really
close with the gracies okay and hoyce
came in and did like a small class and
we all got to spar him when i was like
11. how was it it was the most insane
thing ever he like you know he let us
get him in right now and he tapped out
we're like
[Music]
crazy and he
just showed us like some fundamentals
and it was it was pretty wild to roll
with you it's crazy it's crazy joey you
remember when they had the
uh when they had the the tournament you
know it was like uh
he used to win all the time in the
beginning horse grace always crazy and
then everybody kind of just caught up
caught up to him yeah jiu jitsu was very
special that now you grew up in new york
i grew up in you remember the
yeah
the martial arts thing they did at the
garden every year
no i don't they used to have a martial
arts thing every aaron banks
little hippie dude from new york
jewish guy i think he was you know he
had a [ __ ] all-day tournament and it
ended with a guy
they got they shot him with a 22 and
they bit the bullet out of the air and
how he would do it was they put a glass
in front of him you can see this on
youtube this ain't news you put a glass
in front of him
some little french guy would come out
and shoot it would break the glass and
then he would time the bullet when they
hit the gl
i don't know he died he died they
eventually got shot
but eventually the bullets got beat
because it was a 22. he must have gone
for like a [ __ ] nine millimeter and
he had a special jaw they made like uh
and he cashed the boat he catch the boat
and then spit it on the frying pan
because it was hot
and he did it on wide world of sports
so two or three saturdays in a row
and what you could do mike put that
insert in like show them whatever they
have it on youtube wow what wide world
is sports well i remember the white
world of sports absolutely so that's the
agony of defeat that guy
boom bang and they don't have that show
on anymore they don't know which baffles
me because it was such a great everybody
was home right saturday at five and if
you knew if you didn't even if they were
playing ping-pong you didn't give a [ __ ]
it was the guy falling from skiing right
the guy he did not want to miss him
that dude formed breaking his neck and
bouncing the agony of difficulty and all
that [ __ ] i mean that guy's got to be i
don't know if he's still alive though no
he got defeated
right there wow if he lost an arm that
dude something he lost something in that
accident there was bodies bouncing and
[ __ ] and they weren't you know there was
no walk culture
wow
that's right
it's so weird a fact that people don't
know i googled this years ago
do you [ __ ] know how many
famous people came out of the bronx
you'll never count the amount there's
something in the water in the bronx if i
could do you know what it is it's that
leftover [ __ ] fried banana juice that
they put in the sink that [ __ ] goes
right now
you're in front of the bronx originally
my mother had a bookmaking operation she
had a quality cleaners it was on tremont
avenue yeah
up there i remember i used to go up and
i used to get chased by the
the royal javelins right there was a
bunch of street gangs and i was just
going to buy italian ice on the corner
that was my first real experience with
italian people on the corner there was a
guy that would make uh sherbet sherbet
yeah and you put seven up in it
[ __ ]
bronx had [ __ ] you never tasted it
before you know they had those candy
stores that they making the egg creams
yeah the [ __ ] pizza was to die for
but then we got rid of it like in 71 and
then used to go to the bronx and do
santeria stuff right like to eat fried
bananas and pork chops because nobody
makes a [ __ ] pork chop like a puerto
rican i don't give a [ __ ] when anybody
tells you that skinny pork chops
with some red beans and fried rice all
right i love red beans oh my god i used
to have i i used to you know date these
puerto rican girls and they would make
me uh artis compoyo which i loved i that
was one that's how i got introduced to
puerto rican food and i love all that
[ __ ] i loved all that [ __ ] i love yeah i
love growing up in the bronx people
always go how did you
you know your childhood must have been
really rough and i go it really wasn't i
got it was a beautiful childhood i loved
it it really was i mean did i see some
violent things
i mean obviously i wrote bronx tale from
the killing that i saw when i was
sitting on my stoop
but i had a great childhood i can't
complain about it i really can't i don't
want people to think i lived in this
drug-infested area no it was a italian
name but everybody was italian everybody
hung out everybody stuck together nobody
locked their doors was there violent
[ __ ] that happened yes but i loved
growing up there man you know i just i
loved growing up there i can't help it
man it's a real life
when i would go up there as a child i
looked at it as a real i even went to
the
boys club because we were there
yeah and my mother put me in the camp at
the boys club that's the first time i
realized i was a failure
because i couldn't pass the test to get
the president's exam you got to do like
50 push-ups 50 sit-ups yeah i couldn't
do the pull-ups
i couldn't do the pull-ups yeah pull-ups
are hard man pull up so hard and i used
to give us like a little box lunch and i
i just remember the pizza
okay if i really got to remember
something from the bronx in those days
was how the cheese just dripped the
[ __ ] the flavor i never got that
again it was just that's why i learned
how to eat all that stuff and the
sandwiches
wet muds [ __ ] tremendous
you're like italian [ __ ] dog i grew i
ate that [ __ ]
from the time i was four to like six and
then they got taken away from me and
then i was back in new york city eating
puerto rican food pizza all that [ __ ]
and then my mom had a bar in union city
right so i would have to go visit her
and then finally one day she goes we're
moving to jersey i can't take the
commute no more so we moved to a town
called north bergen and what happened in
north bergen in the early 70s
it was the influx from the italians and
hoboken who were now got like good jobs
yeah it's like moving on up the
jeffersons moved up to the bristol house
brooklyn went to jersey brooklyn new
jersey that's right
uh bronx went to westchester
yes yes so it was funny that
how i never really
had italians around me again to 73.
i went back to north bergen and north
bergen and i i didn't know
those italian people i was raised with
were very special that era of italian
were very special and i couldn't put my
[ __ ] finger on it what made these
like we won the states when i was in the
eighth grade
my high school won the [ __ ] number
one seed
and that one kid was over five eight
the names were avillo and rick posey
and there were these little fire plugs
and they ran behind the high school with
helmets in 90 degree weather to get
better they were they brought the
italian work ethic the football yeah and
they became this team and then i watched
the hbo thing on sinatra
and that's why i put it all together i
always tell people i was raised by
hoboken italians because pretty much
everybody hang out from the barons to
messiness pilanos they're all from
hoboken
it's said that those hoboken italians
used to get tortured by the irish yeah
they were not allowed to go up by 9th
street
they weren't allowed to pass 9th street
the irish you can't tell italian people
not to walk past knight street yeah so
they probably had so much anger they
moved up to north bergen and then got
passed on to me because i grew up with
them yeah but it was a now i had my own
anger from being a revolutionary cuban
when you walked in they had a picture of
adele with blood coming out of his head
next to [ __ ] jesus you know because
the pre-revolutionary cubans hate fidel
they were first generation they figured
out their [ __ ] taken that's right that's
right so they would cry they would
[ __ ] go we're gonna kill that
[ __ ] so here i had these anti
that these italians that were held back
and here i'm coming from an
anti-revolutionary house it's a perfect
[ __ ] combination in heaven for
to anger and throwing things and robbing
trains and [ __ ] lighting bulls on
fire like a lady in our neighborhood had
a little bowling house with goldfish
every night we put liquid fire on it and
light it on fire we burned the [ __ ]
goldfish every morning the chick had
fish and chips for breakfast
it was [ __ ] crazy you know and i
learned that heart that they had and
even now i've moved back here now to
jersey and there's a lot of staten
island italians i've been here two years
i've not heard the language of italian
you haven't no wow these generations
didn't pass that no we didn't do them
see my mother father they said hey
we're american where americans are we
don't speak that language and my mother
did the same thing they did that to me
my mother also said outside you got to
speak english because you're an american
right and here we're still cuban see my
kids he's learning italian my daughter
speaks time my wife speaks tonight all
three except me i'm the only one
i'm the only one
[ __ ] believe that you didn't take it
in high school nothing like that yeah
but i you know i was terrible in high
school i when i went to bronx community
college
you know i went to the community college
i started learning i started applying
myself to really
to better myself well when i was in high
school i just wanted to [ __ ] my own
girls
you know [ __ ] around with my friends you
know it was terrible you went to college
what would you major in did you eat
drama did you yes oh i always wanted to
be an actor okay always even when i was
like 10 11.
10 11 years old because i saw my i
remember my mother used to take me to
the movies and i saw
marlon brando and uh
you know years a few years after it came
out i saw it on tv my mother showed me a
marlon brando on the waterfront
which was my best movie of all time for
me
and i just always wanted to be an actor
i just always wanted to be an actor and
i wanted to write i used to write poetry
back then i wrote lyrics for a song for
songs and
i just
i knew what i wanted to do and that was
it and you were part of a musician also
i was a singer in the band i wasn't a
musician no no but i would write lyrics
i had a hit song on the 20 on the r b
charts went to number 28 a group called
the uh
the song was meet the beat
i can't remember the group that the old
black group that did it
i just can't remember them but for our
rso records but it went to 28 didn't
make any money i got [ __ ] out of it
you know but that's all right you know
back then they just said yeah give him a
[ __ ] cheese sandwich you know
and so i didn't do that but uh
no but but i i enjoyed writing i always
wrote i always write short stories and
things and then obviously what happened
was when i well i couldn't make it
anymore but it's everybody knows the
story i wrote bronx tale um
and my career just took off
it just exploded you know it just
[ __ ] exploded did you see it coming
no i wrote bronx tale to get an agent i
had to get an agent i just
no no no not at all no no all right i
just said i gotta get noticed i got
fired i was working at this [ __ ] club
bouncing because i ran out of money i
guess when i got to l.a i hid it i mean
i got hot for about a year and a half
hill street blues dallas
um
you know i did a couple of bunch of
shows they did a tv movie
and then i ran out of money i started
running out of money again and
finally i i was working at the door and
this guy comes over to me and he really
snobby [ __ ] you treated me like
yours come on don't you know who i am
and when when i work a door and you tell
me don't you know who i am
that's like the kiss of [ __ ] death i
said yeah you're the guy who's not
getting in tonight that's who he goes
you'll be fired in 15 minutes and i said
[ __ ] you i'll be fired 15 minutes later
the man come
the owner comes out because he uh he was
making us who was it swifty lazar
was the biggest agent in the world and i
just told him he can't come into his own
party
it was his party that's why he wanted to
get in there and i got fired
and i went home
and i
in north hollywood i was this [ __ ]
dump i was a shitty apartment shitty car
and i wrote uh i said i'll write this
i'm gonna write about this killing and i
just wrote five minutes of it then i
performed it from my theater workshop
and then everybody loved it and then i
would write during the week and i would
perform it on monday and people would
comment they tell me people say what
they liked what they didn't like and i
feel and i recorded it all on cassettes
and it was great joey because i had a
lot of feedback from a lot of people
you know i was all right this works that
works this doesn't work and after a year
i had this 90 minutes of a one-man show
then my friend lent me money and
my [ __ ] career just busted like like
i literally went from
you know i had credits as an act of
broadway credits but i didn't
and nobody knew me and then i just po
starring at the movies with you know
robert de niro and it was pretty crazy
man but it was like the legend story i
turned it down they offered me um
250 000. i said no i want to play sonny
i want to write this screenplay they
said no no [ __ ] not happening i said all
right forget it then they offered me 500
i said no then he offered me 1 million
200 in the bank swear my mother and
father and i said i want to play sonny i
want to write the screenplay the guy
said to me
we can't make this money
we can't make this movie with you chad's
because pacino wanted to do a nickel
they all wanted to do it and i said no
and then finally two weeks later i did
the show did you ever see the one-man
show no no you got to come and see it
when i said it i did it
and i got off the stage and the guy
walks over to me and and he says hey
brian de niro's in your dressing room
you just saw the show and i said robert
de niro
he was yeah i went in the dressing room
there was bob dynero and he's and he
said man
it was a [ __ ] one man he goes you did
a movie on stage he was that's amazing i
saw thanks bob he goes look
if you [ __ ] sell this thing
eventually they're going to come to me
anyway so he goes let me tell you how i
feel
he goes you should play sonny you should
write the screenplay because it's your
life and it'll be honest he goes i'll
play your father and i'll direct it and
if you shake my hand that's the way
it'll be
i shook his hand and that was it man
boom i took off
what are the [ __ ] odds of that right
so
but
it was pretty incredible
it was pretty amazing and that's what
happened
i still remember walking out of that
movie i was just getting into comedy
i got into comedy in 91
and you're searching
you know the first year you're imitating
dice clay yeah it's true with tayden
kennison i got no i'm not stealing their
jokes right i'm using their character
right
you know you're just trying to feel your
world right i'm doing kenneth in one
week
i'm doing dice the other week you're
doing eddie murphy one week yeah i went
back to pride you know that style of you
know sure talking about drugs one week
you're talking about [ __ ] and you and i
used to wear a suit like lenny clark
you're trying to find your voice you
have to it takes about two years to find
your voice so true and i come to new
york i'm out of money in boulder i got
divorced i'm i'm out i mean i'm just out
and i call my brother come to see caucus
stay here and i start hustling in the
city and it's uh
i start doing spots in the city and i'm
getting spots i'm okay you know
and one night i had nothing to do and i
went to guttenberg to the [ __ ] galaxy
building there on a saturday night and i
walked in to see your movie god's
honesty yeah let me that movie come out
93 or 94. i saw it in like 93 it had to
be 93 august
yeah
because i left new york in october
because while watching your movie
it gave me a plan first of all between
me and you i was gonna shoot you
because i thought you stole my idea
because my mother died and i got raised
by italian so somewhere do you know how
many people have said that to me how
many people said you st i had comics say
to me what was that comic's name i think
he passed away recently he said you
stole my [ __ ] act you stole my
[ __ ] act big petey louis pd fat joke
oh dom herrera used to say no it wasn't
dog it wasn't dog because i love dom
he's great
i can't think of the guy's name
but he told people you tell that guy i'm
suing that [ __ ] and i said you
know what [ __ ] sue me leave me i mean
every every entire neighborhood there
was always a fat guy a small guy a big
guy you know what i mean every everybody
thinks you know steven spinberg said one
thing i'll never forget it
he said success
he goes failure he goes success has one
father failures is an orphan
you know when he every movie he ever
said he made somebody [ __ ]
they stole your idea so you you just
deal with that you go all right yeah
[ __ ] sue me whatever you want but i
didn't i didn't in my mind i wasn't
gonna sue you i just left going
this is the story i gotta tell
this is the type of comic
i have to be right i have to tell my
story from a sympathetic way
it's such a great movie because it's got
so much heart at the end when he meets
joe pesci in there
i mean the movie has so many [ __ ]
things but when i met i left that and i
didn't have a car got no reason to lie
no but i'd have a car i probably had
eight dollars in my pocket and i walked
home
going now i have a direction jesus
i have a direction where to take this i
know
that what i have in my heart the story i
have in my heart to tell is gonna work
from watching your story yeah when i
became a comic i was dirty i was older
so nobody really dug me but i always
knew in the back of my mind if i had a
chance to tell my story i'm gonna eat
these [ __ ] up alive i gotta
tell my story and how it connects
and what happened as soon as i i used to
watch uh those boxing things
inside the hbo you know yeah inside yeah
before somebody's going to fight right
yeah 24 24 7. 24 7. i hate you dante i'm
talking to dante palmer i might hate you
dante but i watched i'm gonna bet your
father against you in that fight
but because that show showed me your
house
it showed me your wife it showed me your
child
it showed me your pool it's not just you
i'mma kill him my right's a great punch
i'm a bad italian stallion no i got to
see the real dante right so i always
knew if i could open my heart up and
that's what happened with you yeah you
got to open what was in your heart yes
then
the [ __ ] and you got to stop the
calls oh my god stop the call forget it
i ain't got a heart i lied yeah no i
don't know nothing if you say right if
you say no nothing
when you say this
when this comes into the whole thing and
you put it on the
stage that's it
and there's a difference between killing
like making people laugh right the
difference between leaving your heart on
stage right jesus christ when you leave
your heart and that's why i can't do
comedy no more because i'm 60 i'm gonna
die when i go on it's like i tell a joke
now i didn't realize it so i moved back
to jersey when we were kids right i want
you to think about this
we look at your son we were kids we
didn't go out to play
we went out to die yeah when we were 12
you don't have to die because
yes
nobody was related to peanuts there was
no elbow braces you know right we went
out to die you know people say
what is the difference of friendship
today
as a friendship when we grow up and
here's what i say because i i really i
kind of dissected it one day i was
thinking about it because somebody was i
had to speak about it on the show when i
was working i did a thing with michael
francis and who i love you're seeing
this podcast uh michael francis who is
with the columbia family yeah
who's just wonderful and brilliant he's
got a great podcast and he i was a guest
on his postcard he became a guest on my
podcast but but anyway i said to them
once i said the difference michael
is what is the essence of what makes
people remember each other forever as
friends
combat
you could be in a war with a guy
think about that and then maybe you
don't see him for 20 years
but if you were in vietnam with him or
if you were in world war ii when you see
each other there's a [ __ ] brotherhood
there you were in war together okay so
take that down a few levels obviously a
lot of levels when we grew up in the
street just like you said when your
friends we were like [ __ ] brothers we
bled for each other we [ __ ] died for
each other we fought for each other
it was no
online or play date it was like walked
down the street you had 20 [ __ ] guys
you hung out together hey
this crew's coming here [ __ ] that crew
you know and you fought together it was
like a brotherhood
so that's what cemented our friendship
i'm still friends with all these guys
for 20
40 years we have dinner once once a year
every year we have dinner in my house
once a year
a lot of guys all
passed on now but
that's what that was the difference
showing the kids today they don't have
that joey i've noticed since i've been
back to jersey that
the friendships i developed 40 years ago
i'm we're still friends you're still
friends there's what i do there you go
40 years has passed yes between us and i
could see that
but when we get on the phone it's like
nothing
it's like freaking frack again you know
it's right it's a really brilliant thing
and that's why i moved here because i
wanted my daughter to have that yes in
california she would have never had that
growing up they just come and go they
come and go here like i said she's very
she's a different child because
of the [ __ ] she's made the friends she's
uh how but how great is that
that's what your job is as a father is
to give your children a life
is to make them to give them to show
them hey man there's just more than this
than out there you know i mean i try to
protect my children i try to do as much
as i can but i try to teach them the
street too as much as i could but
obviously they're not they didn't have
the life that we have but
and good that that's good and that's
good
so let them learn it a little later and
that's okay by me that's how i feel you
know you know look at my daughter i said
the other night on stage my daughter's
nine she got no [ __ ] resume
none right she knows how to play
softball that's it when i was nine i ran
numbers
look out you know what i'm saying you
were looking i was a lookout i went to
the bronx on saturday i think like when
i would tell my mom sadly i want you to
drive me to louie ain't no little league
lewis is paying you fifty dollars to run
numbers and get sandwich for the guys on
saturday and if the number is you get
[ __ ] 75
you know that's what i did in the bronx
and they switch operations every week
gotta go different address exactly
[ __ ] tremendous i will never
not be mad at my mother for that
lifestyle right i mean
when he was nine years old 10 almost 10
he was because i was almost 10.
i looked at him and i looked at my wife
and i said john just look at dante i
said i was that age when i saw that man
kill a man i said if that happened to
him right now i would be devastated that
was devastated
you know i was i was 15 i was 15 and
and this guy
no he's dead little sally ran a [ __ ]
uh
a hula joint you know on top of the card
games
and i would go up there and go hey come
here get me some cigarettes go go and i
would go go get us some sandwiches
at butchers dulling i would go get
sandwiches and finally they would give
me tips and one one of them he looked at
me look i'm 15. joe he goes
he goes ac call me say he goes i say
you want a tip what do you want one
wanted girls and i was like what
he said no no
you know he goes oh i'll never forget
her name my name was foxy
foxy
foxy come here take care of the kid
just like that i'll never forget it and
i was like
i just looked at him he said no go ahead
go ahead
i mean i walked in right you know and
she i'll never forget it you know she
took care of me of course right
[ __ ] man every day i'm going back yo
butch what what you want to say what
you're saying
do you want anything to say
don't worry about it my street
i was [ __ ] back there every day i
never forgot it man every day now you go
to jail oh you know that chicken jail i
know like i i was 15. i have a little
kid around the corner he's like six and
he's always bugging me but i see him
looking at women
and i told the mother i go do you see
this kid he looks at women when they
walk by she's like no she goes last time
when he was four he used me as a wingman
to go talk to a chick so i know he's
he's already thinking of women so i
asked him the one they go how's that
hammer doing he's like huh he didn't
even even know what i was talking about
let me leave it there yeah because this
is not 2020. i had a guy in my mother's
bar his name was al naldo yeah arnardo
de campo a fat little cuban dude there
was a daily bookmaker really and every
day he's saying come here you pissed and
sweet yet
why are you pissing sweet yet
because in cuban the term is mad ducey
is your piss sweet yet whoa what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and then you
always say joey coco you get your dick
sucked yet and i would go what are you
talking like what from the time i was
seven right you're going to jail
oh yeah they'll throw you under the
[ __ ] [ __ ] jail and he said in
front of my mother who's antonio you
dick's up today leave me alone you know
the whole thing and i left here when i
was like 17 once i saw him at a bar
right in union city and i'm like i'm not
i get my hug
and he's telling me like he goes you
look good he goes you're jerking off oh
and i'm like i don't know oh yeah 17 now
he's at this bar and he's in a chair
all right he's talking to me that
there's stools you know like mike's got
a stool they're all on the ball he's
talking to me and my because union city
right there was we catch the bus to go
into the into manhattan right so right
by union city is a post office it's the
last stop on that side on franken tunnel
so i would go to 29th get a hot dog from
the sap right guy there and then take
the bus into the city so i
i forget the name of that bar i went in
there he's in there in the afternoon you
know
and he goes you're jerking off you look
good he goes you gotta jerk off he goes
i'm married 30 years i jerk off every
day he was sitting in a chair like this
and he goes i go home and i wait for my
wife to take a shower and when she's in
there
i start [ __ ]
and he's doing this like he's living
he's just he ain't jerking off but he's
going through the noises he's going to
eat oh hey
and i switch hands and then i do a
cappuccino and then when i come he goes
and he just jumped backwards the chair
went down and he's like
that's the explosion between his legs
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
and then when i was 13 i was swapping
spit with a girl in my room
and my mother cuban mother would say i'm
tony i'll leave the [ __ ] door open
you got to leave the day you know when
you're 13. you try to crack it you try
to but the door is [ __ ] open there's
an inch i mean open i want you to blow
it
you know my mom was one of those huh
so she came home when they went on
naruto and my stepfather they were gonna
barbecue and i'm in the bedroom with
them so they go shut up we gotta find
out what he's doing out there so our
daughter goes i got it so he gets a
ladder and he puts it at the side of the
building and i hear something i'm dry
humping at the earth wind and fire
[ __ ]
you know i'm just there was no sex no
yeah not even a tit we were in the sixth
grade just dry up
and also boom boom what the [ __ ] i was
right here boom
ah the [ __ ] ladder went down he broke
his leg they had to take him to the
hospital i go what the [ __ ] happened did
i they tried to hide it from me i'm not
doing walking up the stairs to see what
you were gonna [ __ ] do
but it's funny how those are the
characters
that we talk about yeah in our lives
because you can't you can't make those
people make this [ __ ] up
you can't make those people up you know
eddie mush that was eddie mush in the
movie in bronx tale that was eddie mush
he was a you know
bob said we got to go find this [ __ ]
guy and we went up to my neighborhood
and we cast eddie mush in bronx deal
that's him
this [ __ ] guy
he was so bad luck
that the bookmakers would not take his
bed no more now you would say why
wouldn't they take his bet he always
lost i'll tell you the reason why
because all the [ __ ] guys would wait
to see who he bet and they would bet the
other way
so he was killing the [ __ ] bookmakers
they said eddie you can't [ __ ] you
can't we can't take your [ __ ] action
no more this is how bad this [ __ ]
bush passed
now hold on one second if we get another
bronx tail two yeah moisture is going to
be lee
you know that [ __ ] call me on
that he's like god damn it out of
nowhere he calls me like at eight
o'clock goddammit god damn it i'm like
lee what he goes you [ __ ] he
goes i would have bet the celtics
tonight but you always tell me i'm much
so i bet the sixers oh you told us that
yeah we since we saw the movie we've
been calling him oh god
is the original i can't even i don't
want to when that vision ufc i mean
while i'm on my phone call yeah because
that call that wire is bad luck i don't
even want him on the wall oh yeah that
was like that he was i would not talk to
him before i put a bed in i didn't want
to hear his bets because they're gonna
[ __ ] my thinking up if he would tell me
i like uh the celtics tonight that's it
i'm not saying he's not even going on
drugs bush was so bad
he always tells the story and it's true
story you say nah come on chaz you're
exaggerating you got two horses that
finished first that he bet one jockey
fell off 10 yards before the [ __ ]
finish line so you disqualified once you
fall off because he jockey he got hit
jockey fell fell off the horse the other
one was uh trotters
horse gets a [ __ ] heart attack and
dies halfway around
and you would say [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll tell you okay when mush
died a friend of our lady of mount
carmel church
okay when he came out we all people went
to the funeral when he came out they
carried the [ __ ] coffin they put the
coffin into hers joey
a [ __ ] flat on the hearse
so now
they can't you know jack it up but thank
god the it was joe body funeral paul
they had another hearse they had to come
there bring that one they took the
hearse everybody in the front of the
church is going you [ __ ] believe this
even in debt
and honest tombstone it says
eddie mush montenero the original bronx
tale
you know what i i love doing it for him
because
he made the guy famous you know and he
did and these guys made us famous yes
they did walk on the bottom [ __ ] boys
[ __ ] i have a friend that i grew up
with he's the best
buck wild italian kid down regal five
foot six 200 pounds bodybuilder yeah you
know he came to my house from [ __ ] can
i tell you a secret i go yeah he goes
hold on one second he starts doing
push-ups
why are you doing pushing he takes his
shirt off because i'm on steroids in
high school back so this went on for
years and then you know his mother died
and everything got a little [ __ ] up
and he got [ __ ] up with the drugs so
when i'm talking to a buddy in my mic he
asked police and he goes i gotta tell
you darren story i go what he goes
darren came to hoboken you know he was
working at this club called shooter's
galleria yeah he goes darren came down
awesome the buzz went off like an alarm
he goes i see darren but i don't think
you know i go down how you doing and he
goes i see darren he goes i forget all
about darren there's an alarm
something's going on in the building
like a fight or something
so he goes
people are running around i don't know
what happened he goes darren comes over
no shirt on
and a disco in a club and he gives him a
20 but it's ripped
he goes darren he goes mike give me a
drink he goes damn the 20s ripped
how's that ripped he go just give me a
[ __ ] drink you know we grew up
together mike gives him a drink he goes
he took the 20 and he asked him for
scotch tape he goes you got any scotch
tape mike goes i'll get it come back in
10 minutes he goes within 10 minutes
guess who comes down the bathroom
attendant he's bleeding from everywhere
darren jacked them up in the bathroom
for coke money the reason why the bills
were ripped because the guy was holding
his money and down ripped the [ __ ]
money from him
you know those people they don't make
them no more they don't make them no
more
they don't want to make those characters
like that
there was this [ __ ] legendary story
in my day with this guy mike he was
tough got tattoos all over him but this
is you know early 60s and they said you
know we heard that mike is gay
i said no get the [ __ ] out of here they
said i'm telling you this guy's hanging
out people the neighborhood's talking
about mike's gay
i said no i said you sure and everybody
starts talking about it
so i'm on a [ __ ] i'm on florida road
once i got to get up to alexander
alexander's was i'm waiting for the bus
and it's raining like crazy the car
pulls up
in a green
61 mustang i'm going to forget it and he
goes
yo
chaz come on in he goes i'll give you a
lift where you going i saw him going up
to you know alexander's on florida road
he goes oh come on i'll give you a lift
it's pouring
in my mind i'm going
yeah i know it's all right i know the
guy from the neighbors i get in the
[ __ ] car he's older than me so we're
driving up and he goes
ah [ __ ] man you hear that i go hear what
because something's with the car so he
pulls over
and he pulls over by the botanical
gardens
you know he pulls over on a side street
now my mind i'm going
nah
can't be right so he gets out of the
[ __ ] car
opens up the [ __ ] hood
and he's standing there with his hand on
the hood like this looking down at the
engine
i wait one minute two minutes three
minutes i go what the [ __ ] he doing so
i get out of the car i go hey mike
what's going on he goes
could i blow you i went what
he goes should i look i said what the
[ __ ]
i said
are you [ __ ] crazy and this was a
tough [ __ ] guy
i said oh my [ __ ] i said i said what the
[ __ ] i'm gonna do i said this guy might
kick my [ __ ] hands and force me so i
said hey pow take me to [ __ ] home i said
no just get he goes i swear to god i'm
sorry don't tell anybody don't tell
anybody he goes just get back in the car
drop you off up there i get back in the
car drive he goes listen don't just tell
anybody i said all right as we i
couldn't write this i'm getting out of
the car right
he goes chaz
please don't tell nobody i said i won't
he goes i'm sorry man he goes there's
only two things i'd like to do in this
world fight and suck i said
all right mike well listen man i
appreciate that thanks for telling me
that i got out of the [ __ ] car i
couldn't write a scene like that
what are the [ __ ] answer and he was a
tough guy [ __ ] but he was gay
he was f but nobody would say nothing
because i said i ain't telling nobody
and i didn't until finally it came out
everybody knew that oh my god
since you said something before i want
to ask you to see what you're hearing
because i just caught the tail end of it
what is going on yeah with mikey
franchise and sammy with his what what's
going on with mikey franchise and sammy
and salmon no i don't know sammy oh
sammy they're at war
yeah something happened i don't know
what happened i i don't know what
happened but i did this thing with them
but i i wasn't obviously i wasn't in the
middle when they were there but
i heard they just had some bad words
with each other i don't know i don't
know what happened because i wasn't
there when they filmed it
but
i don't know i really don't know yeah
it's not good it's been on a lot they've
been fighting i don't know what it's
about i just saw a clip that sammy said
that was it sam is doing a good job with
the podcast yeah he would he's a good
storyteller yeah he is
yeah he's real he's a real dude so i'm
happy that he's doing a podcast i think
he's shooting the movie yeah i think if
i had to if i had to guess
and this is truly stuck a guess i think
there's some animosity between them
because
sammy feels like he's a he's a
he's a gangster
and michael was a racketeer where there
was a difference where michael
you know i i so i think there's some
resentment there i could be wrong
so i really don't know really what
happened but i don't know sammy i never
met sammy but i know michael really well
in fact him and i are going to do a
podcast together our own podcast aside
from my own
but he's just a [ __ ] great guy i love
the guy and i think he's a stand-up guy
man he really is man it's a real sad
he's a great storyteller great
storyteller real smart
and you know he's really like a guy who
who gives his heart he's a born again
christian
comes from a great family like you said
24 7 you see a man how he operates how
he lives and i see how he lives you know
he talks to talk but he walks the walk
man this guy
so uh
again i don't know what's going on
between them and i can't speak for sammy
because i don't know sammy at all but i
know michael and michael is just a great
guy
just a stand-up solid guy man definitely
definitely
but it's kind of weird joey do you find
that weird
i mean you got to admit it joey you have
a podcast i have a podcast
sammy the bull
19 murders
has a podcast
i mean
do you find i and i and i find that do
you like
wow like this country no matter what you
do you got a shot to make it somehow
think about that he did his time he he
did it he did more than enough time yes
he did time for his son and the whole
thing yeah
and if any if you know anything about
sami he's [ __ ] very smart yeah i
don't know oh
did you read his book no i did not if
you read this book i mean listen uh a
situation arose where i was thinking of
doing a podcast with sammy right and
then i had to think about
my world and i think about the people i
mean people have forgotten about it but
some people have it that's what i heard
is that true and well you know it's just
some people feel like you know right and
how good my mother died the italians
were for me there for me i can't tell
you how many times so in my heart i felt
like if i did a project like that
i would spit in the faces of the people
who helped me because that's their
culture and that's their beliefs and
that's the only reason why i wouldn't do
it i think sammy
i think sammy ratted but i think he had
his reasons why he read it it wasn't the
first thing on his mind
i think he was a real wise guy oh no
question that everything was played
against him for him to rat
but you know i was in the roofing
business and
uh a construction tin calls cost 200 in
colorado a construction 10 in new york
the same 10 cost 2 000
and that was because of the mafia tax
that's you know nobody could build
anything in 1985 right and talk to sammy
you know john gotti was the boss of the
gambinos but nothing got done the guy
ran construction projects i talked to an
fbi guy at jiu jitsu and he's going to
find out for me when i told him his face
went white he's never going to tell me
the truth sammy was so
businessy that part of his deal was
defense collecting his loan shark
payments
really they'll deny it everybody will
deny it
but people in brooklyn will tell you i
believe it for about six or seven months
i believe it that's how much of a
businessman he is i believe they paid
off the juror he's the one that told
them that's true to pay him in segments
because the guy can slip on his neck and
break his neck and we already gave him
60 grand why do that let's pay he's a
very good money guy so you can actually
say he was a gangster and a racketeer
and a wrecker yeah i mean you actually
could say that he had a construct he had
a company for everything a construction
company a painting company he had a
construction and what he do is
you know again this is sammy he blossom
the business he give you a shot sammy
let's open up a painting
the place starts making money you're
dead he ain't paying you so he killed
most of his partners
most of those 19 people were partners he
no way architects anybody who did
something for him he iced
the ice bb the potato
[ __ ] that guy owed him two hundred
thousand dollars that guy all owned all
the great the the tire shop so he would
kill his partner he would kill his
partners and then take the business
that's not too cool he [ __ ] killed
his brother-in-law that's right he
killed his [ __ ] brother i heard he
said when he said when he was in the
coffin i remember that i saw that
podcast he said look what you made me do
you [ __ ] and then supposedly he
cut the hand off
so he couldn't find the body and one day
he was in the house and the dog brought
the hand in from the backyard and the
dog he killed his wife's brother
over money well he [ __ ] you know he
wanted he did so many things like he was
on the outs with paul castellano for a
long time well because he was [ __ ]
ice he killed the people from the casino
what's that place in brooklyn you
remember it
gemini dust no
the plaza lounge the play's alone he
shot the guy in the eyeball the guy came
in paid him the three million he was
gonna take over the club sammy killed
him before he could take over the club
i'm telling you the guy was a [ __ ]
but what happened was like when he went
into the fbi a lot of people don't know
about this he went into the fbi and he
read it
and he ran it so well he was so
articulate yeah they said he was
[ __ ]
no he's not [ __ ] but even though
he's got like dyslexia right he was so
professional they fell in love with him
so people would come in that wanted to
turn and they go yeah me and sammy did
this and they look at each other and go
get him out of here he's lying
that's how much they love sammy
so 10 people flipped and would say i
sold drugs with sammy and they go get
him out of there sammy never sold drugs
and it was finally they got together and
they go dog how can 11 people walk in
here and say they were moving quaaludes
with sammy so they had to go back to
sammy and that's a nail sammy was the
last time
was the iceman the iceman made those
tapes right and he said he goes one time
gravano came up to me to kill a cop
when he signed with the fbi they said
the only way we'll take you is if you
didn't kill a cop have you killed a cop
or
a person he did kill a car he's killed
he paid somebody to kill a cop
in bergen county
wow so yeah so sammy was a smart dude
you know i mean and i think the podcast
will do great
well yeah because people will look at
that people you know his podcast does
his podcast does look great he's a great
storyteller he's a great story on
patreon yeah he's shooting a movie right
you know anybody listen the great thing
about this country is everybody gets a
second chance i got locked up yeah i
thought my life was dead you got to say
if you really wanted if you really
wanted i agree make a mistake mike tyson
made a mistake let's talk about my title
oh let's just punch a guy in the face
right this guy didn't beat up bikers in
the bronx
this guy raped a woman okay have you
ever seen mike when he gets on a plane
the first people taking pictures of them
are white women
you see mike in an airport yeah
everybody loves mike yeah everybody
loves everybody yeah everybody loves
mike tyson yeah this guy did one of the
worst things you could do in life right
right
we live in a country he came back he
came back you have to come back you know
arm what's that expression your arm and
your [ __ ] yeah
be humble and you know michael vick
kinda
china he's still mad kind of yeah kind
of
yeah white people's main thing dogs you
don't do that don't do that but mike
tyson mike tyson came to see my one-man
show joey and he cried i believe it
chuck zito brought him yeah i believe it
he cried and he brought him again and he
came over to me and one thing i got to
say about mike and i met mike a bunch of
times
and he said to me
you know you really inspired me to do
that to do a one-person show and nobody
said this to me a lot of people have
said that when they saw my show they say
you inspired me to do it nobody ever
[ __ ] does it they say it nobody ever
done it one of the hardest things in the
world is to write a one-man show you
know that
all of a sudden
i hear he's doing it
he goes on [ __ ] broadway spikely is
directing it i see the show it's [ __ ]
great and i said to him i always told
myself let me tell you something mike
tyson
you [ __ ] did it i respect you more
for that than even all your fights
because nobody could [ __ ] do what you
did
he said he was going to do it he wrote
it he put his heart out there videos
customary all his life it was [ __ ]
great
it was great and he did a great job man
and he did it i respect the guy i love
him to death yeah he's a great i like
the guy a lot and this country's good
with that like now that
they've implemented cancer culture
right and
i don't even respect it
you know you have mike tyson he went in
front of a judge right a judge sentenced
him i went in front of a judge he
sentenced me right who the [ __ ] are you
that sentence me
who the [ __ ] are you to sentence me
right you can't judge me when the fight
and for pete and the people that are
doing it are people that are saying that
work
so you woke but you don't believe in a
second chance i believe in a second
chance you've got to take a question
from a guy and make him embarrass
because you say a girl 12 years ago now
i sympathize for her i have a daughter i
understand absolutely but you can't come
back from 20 [ __ ] years ago
there's a different time we don't know
what's going on well uh kris knock
walked into a restaurant he grabbed my
ass he was chris not [ __ ] he was on sex
in the city i'm sure you didn't smile at
him or nothing but why would you see
what bothers me is i don't like you come
back 15 20 years ago i mean
because i think about when i was single
okay i didn't i didn't do i didn't do
anything like that but
when you're a single guy you come on to
a girl
as long as you do it like a gentleman
what well he was inappropriate what he
said
look i was [ __ ] coming on to you i
was [ __ ] 22 years old what the [ __ ]
you want from me now time out he was an
appropriate what he said now ladies how
many guys come up to you on a daily
basis and say can i have your number and
you're like i'm flattered but i don't
want to or hi can we walk on a date and
you're flattered but you don't want to
don't you want a guy to come up to you
and say because i'm no handsome guy but
whenever i said this line it was to go
first man who talks loses how about we
go back to my place i got a gram of coke
and i'll suck your [ __ ] uterus out
you don't say nothing after that you
just look at the bar
and you turn around oh jesus if they
follow you
you gotta hit her if they don't follow
him everybody goes their own way i had a
friend an italian kid with blue eyes
yeah guy got more [ __ ] than anybody i
saw him and when he was 17 pick up a
girl on the beach and take her under the
boardwalk and they came back holding
hands whistling and they [ __ ] in 69
under the seaside boardwalk and i said
enough with this [ __ ] i got to listen to
what this [ __ ] was following
girls right he's indian he was italian
but his mother had a little bit of
indian in him so when he got drunk he
got obatz right so he would tell women
like and his eye would roll i'm gonna
[ __ ] suck every pubic hair out of
your [ __ ]
girls want to hear that they don't want
to hear that i'm gonna take you to
dinner
i have insurance i got a 401k oh you
don't want to hear that you want to hear
you're going to suck my [ __ ] till you
smell my liver
smell your [ __ ] i'm going to put my
[ __ ] right in your [ __ ] my nose in
your ass i'm going to smell your liver
you tell that to a chick she'll look at
you and at first it's like this sexual
harassment
sounds like fun
it sounds like this sounds like [ __ ]
disneyland here so you don't really know
how to i know that's the only thing that
worked for me when i went up to a woman
as a gentleman
they didn't want to talk to me i like to
take you know i have to admit i was
always a general yeah you got to be a
gentleman but after a while you're 30
you're like enough with you know when a
girl is 20. yeah i want a guy that's
dark and you know he smells like colombo
and the [ __ ] is dirty yeah yeah he
could be a little chubby company
well the
dropping yeah the standards keep talking
as you get older because that [ __ ]
prince ain't showing up to your house
you know what i'm saying
yeah when they're young when they're in
their early 20s they're like the
handsome guy with the six years but as
they get older they go this guy just
wants to bang me this older guy here is
going to take care of me a little bit
and that's why i won't talk to young
girls yeah no like listen i didn't like
when i was 18 i still like 29 year old
women right i didn't want to hear that
cheddar chatter you you take a catholic
girl home she gives you a tip you got to
walk home and paddle the whole way
she's crying these irish chicks they cry
on the way home and i love irish chicks
you know that right right i love italian
women but they yell too much
they yell too much
the irish chicks like me because i'm
their father
irish women have crazy dads
that's true they beat the kids they
drink they call them [ __ ] they
drink okay so the only women who ever
wanted to have anything to do with me
was irish chicks i'm cool the irish
chicks they're like he's okay he's like
my dad right well my wife says it to me
she might keep becoming my dad
holy [ __ ]
i love irish women yeah they got dirty
feet
they got that little dirt on the heel
you know what i'm saying like when you
go to [ __ ] what was the porno check
on 42nd street when we were kids you go
in there space land sex land section you
went in there the thing opened up and
you put your head in the thing
for like a quarter but if you didn't put
a quarter in the slot the thing shut on
your window i have a friend paris he's a
cop in san diego right in the eighth
grade we play hooky went over the sex
land the window caught him we walked out
like we didn't know nothing we just
walked out
it was a circle with rooms right a guy
would walk out dante tremendous and a
guy would come in with a bucket with hot
water and you're free to go in there and
your feet would be sticky and [ __ ] on
the wall
and it'd be like i would take the
bus into the city and i'd come out of
port authority maybe quarter eight
and i would see the hasidic jews walking
into sections that's right by
the [ __ ] dozens yeah and at eight a.m
it was the chicks that were hooking and
they're just coming in for like one last
20 dollars
so it would be like a rotating stage
it'd be like a rotating stage and this
chick would be on heroin
and she'd be passed on there'd be some
guy like banging her and you're like
sitting there like what the [ __ ] is
going on what's happening with my life
but i'm in here i might as well bang one
out you know what i'm saying
and then this little ugly chick walking
around from window to window do you want
to suck my tit for a dollar do you want
to suck because you have that little
hood so you could stick your head in
just like kid when you're in the eighth
grade you know
you're living like a doctor that's
living in new york man
that's the new york [ __ ] experience
that's the new york experience you're
right man you're [ __ ] right so he
tells me he goes
you know dad you should have brought i
mean you know you we shouldn't bring
something to joey we're going to his
house
i said well i we can't stop now it's too
[ __ ] late i don't want to be so late
i go yeah i should have brought him like
i should next time i come i said i'm
going to get him some cuban rum some
really
he goes trooper wrong he don't want no
[ __ ] rubs he goes giving out some
[ __ ] weed i said i'm not giving him
no [ __ ] i can't do that that's
terrible you don't smoke no i don't i
did you did and
oh years ago my thing was lsd i love
douglas thing
mike my city
thing was lsd but i'm older than you but
when i took lsd in the late 60s we used
to have a f it was really [ __ ] strong
joey we used to go i was in a band you
know i had a long hair down here so we
used to go to this guy's house we all
walk in he goes all right guys i made
some good [ __ ] today you have you have
an eye dropper like you know you go like
this stick out your tongues we will
stick out of tongues
all right man we pay him walk out of
there see the thing about lsd you know
was like this is it for 12 hours eight
to 12 hours this is it there ain't no
coming down [ __ ] i'm back there
ain't no coming back
this was it
he didn't know that i took a drug till
he was about 22 years old he just asked
me growing up dad come on you never
[ __ ] smoked pot and i go never never
when he was 22 finally when i started
writing this book that i wrote
then i started coming out i said i
wanted to wait till he was older because
i didn't want to give him permission
at that age you know what i mean but but
no i was lsd we used to spike each other
joey me and my friends
we used to spike each other we could
we'd never eat in front of each other
we'd never eat because i went and i was
i was one of the last guys to get
[ __ ] spiked so i'm sitting around my
friend timmy knapp god rest his soul i
said timmy we got to spike the guys i
said but what is a food that nobody
couldn't resist and he goes i don't know
he or should we get muslim like oh no
it's too big he goes
oreos
oreo crackers
so we get all real crackers joey so he's
like there i'm over here just like this
so i said he goes do you want a trip i
said i don't want a trip because all
right let's just spike him i said okay
he goes but i want to eat something i go
it's very simple the good piles here the
bad piles there that's the bad pile
that's the good part i said we take out
of the good pile so we're doing like we
i'm getting the purple
purple haze was that was the [ __ ]
acid and we grind we smashed it all up
the powder form and we'll go like this
open up the oreo cookies
right so we're putting in the bad pile
so [ __ ] bad you know this so he ain't
looking i'm putting some of the
bad ones in the good part i'm throwing
him in like
i'm throwing him in right so he's going
like this he's taken from the good pal
20 minutes 30 minutes combing goes
hey chad this [ __ ] comes through your
hands i said what are you talking about
demi he goes
he goes man i feel like i'm [ __ ] you
know you get that foot in your
mouth you know he goes
i said timmy come on stop it that's the
good pal that's the bad pile he goes
i keep throwing [ __ ] in the [ __ ] he
goes what the [ __ ] he goes something's
going on
i can't [ __ ] believe it i'm tripping
i go you can't be true but he goes
please tell me you [ __ ] spike me
please i said all right i [ __ ] spike
you and he goes oh thank god he thought
he was losing his [ __ ] mind
so i took some of the [ __ ] bad ones
and i said are you happy now look so we
both started tripping we waited till all
the guys come in so everything's on top
of the [ __ ] right oreo cookies every
guy walks in just like i said joey
hey every guy's grabbing him taking what
i'm saying we'll [ __ ] laughing right
not gonna go open the door it's a
[ __ ] super the building older guy
back then he must have been like 50. he
walks in he goes how you guys doing
everything all right you guys are okay i
said yeah we're okay he goes oh he goes
can i have a couple
so everybody's standing there so what
the [ __ ] are you gonna we go yeah yeah
go ahead
he takes a [ __ ] couple to make a long
story short but like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
bill bailey his name was bill bailey
bill billy took the [ __ ] oreos what
was somebody tonight we weren't now we
told everybody they're all [ __ ]
laughing they're pissed off at us but
we're all laughing we find out that bill
billy was power walking by the bronx zoo
he was walking like this
i mean you know but my thing was ella's
thing we used to take down that i love
that [ __ ] i got three hits in the draw
no
no i couldn't joey they would have to
they would have to take me to the
hospital right now
if i ever took it now seriously i can't
do it joe take three hits i'm gonna have
your son drive we'll go all right
go down the shore we'll go down to point
please and jump up and down i would say
take me to the [ __ ] hospital because
shoot me up with dorazine and just let
me [ __ ] let me tell you something if
you took this you'd be disappointed yeah
it's not what we were getting oh it's
three hours
three hours oh this was twelve eight to
twelve this is three hours maybe a two
hour afterward where you see like a
streak or something
i'm saying
you feel something scratching your neck
but it's not what we we got they don't
have i used to look in the mirror she
look at the mirror yeah and everything
melts everything melts i used to go
that's right i should grab my nose and
it was like
right off my face my eyes
i remember sitting in a chair i remember
when i went to this party once it was
like nine o'clock at night i'm sitting
in the chat look the time was right
there it's at nine o'clock i went oh
[ __ ] nine o'clock all right man come on
we got a great pot i look up i see the
ceiling going like this
[ __ ] breathing and i went
yeah man that's cool also i look down
and listen i turn back and look at the
clock it's [ __ ] two in the morning i
said how the [ __ ] did that happen four
hours they fly i was flying
the ceilings where the things would fall
from yeah
i mean one time that's the same thing
because they the popcorn they go like
that and then if a thing happens to fall
you start thinking the whole roof yes is
gonna [ __ ] fall down but you
you get these [ __ ] things it was like
and and sex was like off the [ __ ]
shots well you know that was like when
you you and the girl both did it i mean
yeah i never found the girl that could
do that [ __ ] i was doing i was doing the
double breath double barrel sunshine
sunshine and uh brown dot the brown dot
window paint i did stones in foreign in
philadelphia i wouldn't leave the hotel
room i was like the kid in apocalypse
now i don't want to go
i don't want to go i don't want to go
and they're like you got to go it's
going to be okay yeah well but that [ __ ]
was that's good [ __ ] i like it yeah i i
will i won't forget that about mushrooms
never did mushrooms give me diarrhea
never did mushrooms they gave me
diarrhea i couldn't do much i just never
did it i just
and the pot today is too [ __ ] strong
and the part that is strong
too strong
really violently strong stronger
yeah we were smoking mexican gold red
18 no
black dungey maybe 14
this [ __ ] now it's 37 40 they have that
[ __ ] you could smoke with a [ __ ] blow
torch i don't do none of that stuff i
just smoked that's it i can't i don't
drink no no i haven't gone high since
the 70s man i mean i just said boom that
was it i just don't do anything man but
i remember this guy came into we i was
living in st thomas in the virgin
islands with the band and the guy said
hey i got some opium
i said opium he says yeah want to smoke
smoking i said
i said oh i never smoked opium before he
was
and we're all sitting around we're all
like who said yeah let's give it a shot
it's all right so i said uh anything you
want to tell me he goes yeah where you
smoking that's where you'll be
and i went
oh i said come on i said i [ __ ] we
get hired i said give me the [ __ ] day
i took a few hits joey i leaned against
the wall and i went
i started sliding down the wall
and i [ __ ] stayed right there it's
like a dream thing that's why they have
opium thems i didn't realize that he
explained to me they have dreams where
you just like
you know you go into a you just dream
you smoke i did it once and i was it i
could never do it again i couldn't it
scared me because
lsd didn't scare me this [ __ ] scared
that's just and once you start getting
older you're like i can't i don't want
to even do that [ __ ] yeah no i love to
go to a chinese thing and smoke opium
and egg rolls and [ __ ]
that that time passed you know what i'm
saying yeah no i couldn't i i just and
especially now i i have this thing about
wasted talent and i try to totally you
know i have this thing about telling the
kids you know i said look i got high and
i did it i understand you know but
you know you gotta after a while you
gotta just get your [ __ ] together man
and so that's what happened i got my
[ __ ] together and everything worked out
from there but
dog this has been an honor having you on
here thank you joey i said bronx tale
woke me up wow and it gave me a
direction now i knew what i wanted i am
so [ __ ] flattered that you i mean i
didn't know that i never knew that but
what i hear people say about bronx tale
you know i hope you get a chance one day
to come and see it i am i think i'm
going to go to september 10th yeah you
got a show in pittsburgh yeah in in in
in jersey
is it to pennsylvania pennsylvania yeah
if you just go to
chazpaletery.net everything is up my
schedule is my niece saw you at the
saint george field well she came yeah oh
not the one in red bank the same thing
because when she came to me and she goes
i went to see chad [ __ ] tremendous
what are you telling me oh anytime you
want to come you gotta look at you i
love you i love
dante looking good
nice italian smiles he looks like
something other [ __ ] gq magazine he
does
very handsome i know i always tell
people my son is an actor singer
songwriter go to dantepalmutari.com
you read all about you hear all about
him and i'm happy he came today i love
you [ __ ] thank you for supporting
i'll be back wednesday don't forget to
follow the man of the hour
chaz p i love you see you monday and now
for a word from our sponsors
all right you filthy animals
i want to thank chaz i want to thank
[ __ ] mike i want to thank chad
everybody who [ __ ] showed up today
especially you [ __ ] suckers on a monday
morning i love you listen the joint is
brought to you by freeze pipe
listen you're sitting there you're about
to watch a good movie you're like i need
a little breath of fresh air you rip out
that [ __ ] freeze pipe you put it in
the freezer you pack your little bung
you rip out out of the freezer you
connect it to the bong or the bubbler or
the pipe and you [ __ ] blast off when
you rip the hot smoke passes through
your [ __ ] frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale
listen your smoke would be so cold you
could blow ice cubes up people's
[ __ ]
listen i love this [ __ ] freeze pipe
it's tremendous i live off the [ __ ]
pipe it takes me to a different level i
see the devil on a daily basis
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds of degrees and i'm getting
flashbacks of snowmass village 83.
and your uncle joey's going to take k.a
on a monday morning go to
thefreezepipe.com
press and code joey and save 10 off your
first order who takes care of you like
that on the monday nobody gets your bong
piper bubbler today not tomorrow today
that's the freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
if you could smoke from it freeze pipe
makes the dick about to come out with a
frozen apple [ __ ] tremendous the
joint is also brought to you by
manscaped listen it's the [ __ ] the
summer's coming beach weather you want
to have your dick balls everything ready
to go tip top we're going you want to
smell good that's why you got to get the
ultra the ultra smooth package you
understand me what are you talking about
joey first off you lather up you see
where you're going with the shaving with
the clear crop gel shaving gel
tremendous and it refreshes it feels
like you got ice cubes in that area it's
time to shave now right tick tock you
use the crop shave it's designed for
shaving around the [ __ ] kakuza or the
minkier stick all the products ultra
smooth package of vegan cruelty free and
sulfate free you get 20 off your first
order and shipping with code joey at
manscape.com did you hear what i'm
[ __ ] saying to you why do you have
that clown living between your [ __ ]
legs it looks like bozo that's 20
percent off plus free shipping with code
joey at manscape.com
smooth out the fellas with the relaunch
of the ultra smooth package
from the fellas at manscape listen
everybody's gonna thank you especially
your [ __ ] nut sack
that down there sweating all [ __ ] day
i want to thank manscape i want to thank
freeze pipe but i want to thank you
savages for being savages on a monday
morning stay black i love you
see you wednesday
[Music]
you